[Music]
hi welcome to the class that's not being
recorded but it still is that says were
technologically this is what the pianist
just over the world right Arjun okay so
republished paradise everybody's
favorite class especially me and most
people are always missing me telling you
add up show games I lose I have a good
excuse
Arjun yeah that's right he didn't finish
yesterday you wear the skirt line okay
but we'll start of the game that I lost
okay so now that I lose but was not
alike is walking us so I'm playing a
tournament that's like Rufus and doofus
and if I come into top five or so I
qualify for the US Championship and if
everybody was playing it terrible
and then I lose in like 20 moves except
I didn't needed to apply to the doofus
and I didn't mollify oh okay no talking
all right so just that's the conceal
just keep doing it certain uses you
confuse that okay so this is my game
with Dimitri Schneider who's sort of
with chefs and his brother Igor stranger
who also put chest probably likes 2300
plus tax and to make sure got the 2500
plus tax but since they're from New York
it was too much to actually play
Brereton okay alright so in this
position which is very complicated
because there's a bishop here and this
is all here and so way now blessed last
move was to play Knight takes my knight
so I should take that but in fact Li the
douchey hood which lost the game
unfortunately I wasn't playing any of
you maybe not Claudia but I wasn't
playing like a lot
so my groom was punished swiftly into a
little [ __ ] okay no talking
so I play Queens a v6 with no Saudi I
apologize and as soon as he is iying
I show the movie good pleasant with web
but wait a min he's in the reciting he
putted them to the one then I resigned
ting aye so raise your hand if you're
not arching you never won research you
can raise your hand if you brush it yet
if I went into jr. are you looking long
everything we really have forged our big
way out Heidi
194 that's the winning it wins to life
well we want plastic man likes you so
it's 94 triple question mark plus tax
things we did before
yeah that's the K left special right you
got to do your charger for trademark
infringement maybe see who these your
hand also that you move legal that was
legal
that's better okay 95 is what I expected
okay and then I played the obvious move
me for my last time and you'll notice in
this position white is up apart because
lights up upon alright so I saw those
who you suggested and I was like I'm
saved and then warrants Olivia came and
he's like kind of us which movie a heap
along wonderfully no he doesn't know
yeah even thoughyou father you don't
talk about the Arabian look here what he
doin what he plays did I call it works
Olivia and he confuses Lawrence of
Arabia with the horse Olivia's oh yeah
nineteen did you get a tough lift for
Alzheimer's you do it yeah exactly
are you in the wrong answer what system
works clear sits right I'm a
construction he pride is in the event
no I'll take the wrong move I said with
the wrong answer I think he can save you
I'm choosing her I'm done teasing you
now it's his turn
okay so the frenzied answer obviously is
he wants to discover check me
but those allow me to play three days
before that was the response to all
discover checks except the one where
it's illegal now I can't like we did
before I wasn't a great ask for 2001 so
right so I can't play these things
before so I can I check a normal way but
they takes my clean you'll notice them
down the keys because I'm down at peace
but when I see three at least they also
say further big shows we oh okay he just
say and my life's not really a task
because the night is spin so I can't do
that unless I'm going to one o'clock
then you can do the reward so I could
say and you would say then you agree the
flexibilities so Mike lead lead v6 mood
was a blunder 95 check and I lose damn
and every other great Shaq I just saved
his Bishop and I assume he would save my
queen but he didn't we played 95 and
didn't take my queen was that actually
called let's call the randoms to Ken
West
and your New York I watched how long it
is yeah concern that says one word one
word there you go that's what I was
going to say but he let me sit in these
few times because he learned right yeah
also okay left were you going to say
that oh I didn't say nice can we keep it
I said about perfect okay
so I lost we'll forget about that okay
now everybody made fun of my opponent
for losing immediately except where I
saw this position to everybody they
don't see how I win so they would lose
the same way alright so in a previous
move my body blundered with the exertion
I would say
is after c5 this weekend retreat you
know he did Arjun you want a sweater
what could we do very and so now that he
can't retreat I'm going to win his queen
because winning his queen is good
they're taking notes so the qu een so I
played birthday one attacking his Queen
he plays the obvious road we can be two
previously if I had played birthday one
he could have retreated its Queen to one
of these squares so as soon as he plays
d5 I was like all weekend retreats Queen
now if attacking it my queen detail and
now White has one winning move and this
is very funny I have a long complicated
story about this okay which carol like
because she will let the other person
your story why not the other for school
wait interrupting my story okay so I'm
playing in the spice coupler was in
tactics that's when Susan was in Texas
and I was in the bead room because they
indeed group I'm not mad then I won't
get 0
anyway playing in the a group somehow
was at obedient okay and then I plays a
winning move which plenty of army
suggests so how the highest for the
players overdrive
Bishop c4 I hit the clock I wrote it
down I walked around Nakamura style and
a KO he was walking around and I kicked
them and he looked at me or I don't like
that
when he looked at me funny what do I get
up my name is look like because usually
if would have appeared off you know when
they give immediately so my fourth tire
is in me and his name is a lot cooler
than mark right right article Arjun when
I can't go out either water lagoons
Libya or 101 uses all what correctly I
think you've got some correctly
there or the two mistakes okay okay so I
said this is c4 in this position I can't
really win as Queen because I don't have
enough firepower
now requisition c4 other than Claudia
what is wife threatening if I can move
again what would what you do why is this
thing to people every time just breathe
it over there you bring this was the
entry what's like threaded with my dream
:
anybody can left locate you what I
confidently said if your home couldn't
hear can watch and you couldn't he's
like relate to another way how did you
know he saw a good mystery why the
currently working to in the greenest
tracks and that's why wife's legs ajussi
for right right so now black has lots of
defenses to that
but with Simon is are focusing on this
room you each time same place
you know you never heard of studying or
garden and you don't know what that
means
you know that their last name right what
exactly like I mean the golf ended up
yeah so there's no good fence to rotate
to the engine suggests b5 ripping to
takes taste very suspicious
so after this is c4 he views on like a
fin 2540 and when the game is and I went
outside and I sign autographs all that
stuff
several people said why did you play
such a quick draw I said I wonder like
you 115 moves might once have risen yeah
exactly
yeah I actually got a GI workup in
tournament Korea but around to go $9,000
there's good and there's not good not
good what shows that problem margin
that's very close it's a show you how on
the watch that's also closed its The
Sopranos he's supposed to say what's
that
Biron Spring Street for me yeah catches
it if I notice Sopranos team with it
happens and they got Suez of Abbott
shows already okay so in The Sopranos
moving walk by that for several minutes
now that makes that's right he's like
what okay
who's more confused Arjun are you
you said you is he way yes
anyway they're Sopranos Christopher his
girlfriend is the music agents and her
Sayers the worst singer who ever lived
she's like he's great so her boyfriends
like he's great
so takes it to a real music producer as
a listen to her and why it's not good
because what do you mean good they're
good that's not good he's right okay
that was hash obviously horses are for
him so I hope you're all doors you are
soprano - now you're talking okay Arjun
with my unit okay so obviously what lon
Apple kid story about this game - so
this guy's name is Fabio - Jota
right and he's from Cuba he's from
Colombia not that that Missouri
absolutely you were didn't coming to
Earth it already yep yeah he goes our
slogan is there and the coca this point
okay so you can edit that anyway a
friend of mine who was there at the
Colombian guy who wasn't him he says you
don't thought you were really what one
yeah from Colombia since to them mean
anything that's like as funny sort of
name is there a meaning in Club he said
yes about the old auto-da-fe ho na ho
and definian
really upset him he's just thinking
doesn't fighting - alright
later he moved to Florida and play the
US Championship your favorite player not
here
waking up 20 years ago okay so in this
position I'm threatening rook takes b5
as I said so you agree what can he stop
it with a for this display as the world
chess festival in Canada in st. John
Washington the wrong pocket and then
we'll do it all kind when I tracked him
you we got the red columns you're
supposed to say you Finland I would say
that st. John's he's like oh my god
and be embarrassed don't sit lessons you
know they'll tell you know all that yeah
so Saint John New Brunswick nobody's
heard of it st. John's Newfoundland now
you're also when we got there we were
driving around there was a sign
everywhere for no reason saying urban
and we're like urban observing it
serving everyone everything was urban
that turned out he was like the third
richest person in Canada he like owns
like New Brunswick and he died about a
year ago but now he's so now you don't
worry when he has time you not
absolutely not okay so this was this
wall chess festival which was in Saint
John New Brunswick O'Neill's life they
had all the candidates matches they had
two huge international tournaments where
first prize was 10,000 years of I will
give the caveat that was 10,000 Canadian
so any like what okay and then they also
had the world blitz championship which
was a knockout regarding a first prize
in a blood tournament in 1988 was
$50,000 that's like 1 billion dollars
today by Ken yeah it's better than all
the best players in the world with all
of them
no I said all the best players burn at
Shell mostly it is all five and I said
anyway who wants a tournaments me the
random players that if all five for no
detective
lucky her Kyle they hopefully and you
saw a woman
what month February they see da and I
give them their now you know one hey
infantry 88 granite Thomas I mean he was
good he wasn't like me he was going to
anybody pick a key determining guy's 84
85 so he did not read he did one in
seven oh wow well yeah Mario as usual is
correct this is pretty Houston about you
know smear it was I forgot huh yeah yeah
it was it was a short victory yeah it
got all won by heating my light on in
the last round 4 0 it was a match to
wear out bottom 4 0 70 minutes that
would do it no 116 that she was a 3-0
anyone watched it now that to funny
things have in the world list festival
championship to me
what is this far off was play Gerald
your GM your favorite your death and he
had a Queen and Bishop knows it and
Georgia had a king also the further he
came and it was Ross Tillman he had on a
midwife so that was been sent me and
your get one that so I just wrong okay
the first thing that happened was in the
match between modern young and I face
hero Fergie up it was written to again
struck the two ponds were winning Empire
you having this King and Wednesday at
the clock and as a province of his game
and when he was hit the clock before he
hit it the guy took his king which would
make care America's he move a predictive
on and learning he went or he get really
lost position with awareness pot if you
don't hit the car in the who's illegal
if you hit
single yet you can say they're legal
volleyball so the nobody is the cocker
not because this part was running but he
could have hit it and then they're going
to finish it
however even though it's 1988 they
videotaped the whole certainty so they
went to the videotape and it's other
slow-motion replay no fraud D going
missing like ah showing he didn't have
the thought then they had C fights
that's another one okay he's about a l1
that was the first videotape no matter
what I've ever seen which is to turn
their welcoming
no absolutely not ah that's public okay
so as you're hearing all of that what is
the winning combination that black play
when Ken was using his fingers let's
give a chance here what okay station
which one on B no repetition was right
at the other one
what about four people ago I'm kidding
you're willing to talk about whether
they defy this correct okay and why play
the obvious world over cases right now
this move may be too hard for Kent last
1995 is a reasonable hope but it's not
the best it doesn't lose benefit hi
that's the famous Payless it's
reasonably double lose good job not
alone then he worked at 94 s ksenia
terms a caterer obviously he knows
neither state deport shot now in the 1
o'clock class they suggested two moves
here this should be for like King c2 if
you get into any luck within the way I
cool alright so obviously Freddie play
this King Big D for then meat is good
for black how does the color business
always a draw
it's not so various right
this gives away my kitchen last time the
last two hi so he played the obvious
move that I would be best but he's
Internet king daeso is king before this
is some kind of format orders table this
home it's called me taking all of your
visas I would say admission all right
she's like you need to crack wait what
happened who down excellent now I play
the obvious yeah he never seen these two
maybe three she budget plan feature now
you may have noticed I'm attacking these
two pieces you may have also noticed you
have three legal moves because that can
show those legal moves unprotect your
rug because this rock is protecting this
truck so if you move this K to the back
brave I take the road for free
therefore he played he can't keep it now
most of you will take the run and then
you take that what is Archer likes to
say I play the Internet so why what was
there too risky to check because I
wanted King to go to the back right but
i could take that rough he didn't want
to go to the back ranked city like this
is Ito and I took that now he good III
or Z 153 I check them and then I take
his rock and he's like we're my piece of
shell okay and also this is very similar
to the game I dressed up in dead I just
made it up without saying let's treat it
I'm very impressed with myself
and not working that's right because I
was a bad girl it's like okay the
difference is you don't you yeah well
there's somebody yeah so he didn't like
any trees like anyone now it's pretty
good for Wyatt because you have to leave
your way correct very good you said I
next line are to pay attention recording
us gold how many gold yeah okay now
again if I take this rock he takes my
rock because I'm done defending my rock
so I know my look light and pick
something all magnet now you have an
issue I'm going to figures rug
if this hurt moves off the board aka
vertically I'll player be one check in
with his rock therefore deflected remedy
one okay and there's Audrey's because on
the mysterious au jus like that okay and
that I placed year and then the director
came in said to mom to stop no that's
true because position isn't about yeah I
didn't know the story that I forgot but
in this tournament
Carol directly who's been an arboretum
record including this year right of us
championship she forfeited Kamran
Shirazi
because International Master you never
heard because he wasn't keeping score
and he says when I go to gable in 12b
just anyone who's going and she's going
here to keep score and he's like I'm
calm our trustee and I'm like boy and
she's what up getting forfeited poplar
populus to get over into the st. Charles
Montrose yeah that's right but she's
like two games over your room is like
looking at my team or so therefore you
win you can we revisit yeah so the
nominee was the Boston camera can do is
about meals losses now
you can talk with you the answer I want
you can't be here
who's the boss yeah is a better integer
actually I'm feeling a target for the
boss was on that show then they are the
way the motor is dead
waitress is better family I approve the
incident you that's correct
oh that songs about does the insert is
only yeah they were better than after
that song so he wrote Born to Run I know
is there earth something like that okay
it's even more the one I don't know
important the other side you know that
you're doing to what I know yes that he
was in this boat alright now this is why
8 million so he resigned where if you
don't believe me Claudio right good for
what club this one I prefer black yeah
this is so many that you have to get
better a chest in our Anita's little bit
home in that much you get four years ago
when I was twelve hundred on the planer
wow that was so many many realize how do
you think it'd be possible
yeah so yeah we're faced be fine
actually I think after this move it
equal and this move plaque is slightly
better or astroturf Hearts II would say
tiny little Becker okay
English here after this it's like plus
to know mean cushion
okay and the game right side Fabio's
against a courtesan towards us I can
help
all right next this is what whatever
girl sweet okay now yeah I'm playing
injure wisely and cut out I drop me near
your Dunkirk yeah well I was Chevy SS g
spoke at all so obviously frankly I was
living in Belgium at the time this is
the middle of my goblins Day 1990 and I
boys from England obviously because a
prior Jamie turns away here expensing
Alvin camera gimmick that's when I
played lady they played like every game
plastic means wisdom begins I want
another students okay and he plays Ouija
too now in this position obviously but
is better because my thing is the safest
in her and I had a trial put an age
where and the coordination
flattener kakaako's moves where he's
much better be off plus one plus 0.9
hugger
I played move ride left horn and then
then I let's do is flip it and it was
this and word of [ __ ] timing that's
pretty good with the material equal well
here +70
equal no good position but there's like
one of them to does that that's why a
public paradise other question is was
the sign with this game played with four
games
1997 well you're nestled against is very
questionable are going to tell us Road d
2h 6 with these kind of lessons right
there what class nope nobody reads there
in publicize all be together but there
were 40,000 people watched yes so I'm
gonna ask you another question
in your opinion who wanted to treat
weeds that is efficient which again I
think mistake
see there you go does anyone play can
write the mess for money all the into
another connection they're confused ok
here we did you give some odds can you
ease muggy the American so no one wants
pretty Queens because like being
generated but he accepted is you don't
want any he's not important so your king
is say you want to keep leaning on the
board after your look with redness I
guess nothing I think is not that I
would refuse anyone I buzzing marking up
because always we watching
I don't [ __ ] exam yeah funny thing
goes off right
you're always yeah but can I just answer
your don't talk to that however I got it
make that seven correct one eight seven
because we're going to do a final gun on
the fly metallic eyes gun but I'm going
to Troy so this is more dangerous it
cleans seconds in there yeah well first
well your you do that I was here with
Jerry to happen on and so now I'm going
to play up a schtick and you're going to
be unhappy yeah yeah that's like Queen
8:23 Queen but my wreck h1 then you
don't like that and yeah there's no
nothing you do you know your flavor
basis or h1 and can do anything about
Wow can't imagine I go to jail anything
for skinning it with a Kobe fighter show
I get anything every picture that's what
was they are family that's like anything
you feel aggression you so crazy some
big shot what we must crazy do i plot
what never fire six preceptory never but
you've every right what do you want to
play f3 and you want to run away like a
comedian a war right what if I came here
was that way you play that three yeah
well then are you here what
right here
that super black oh yeah this is you win
the Queen yeah okay done folder wasn't
it there that I thought he was not that
uses exactly
I've liver it said I'm sorry Alicia
he plays G for Allah very good
that is my class Ricky says Queen G 3
C's not as dumb as you look seems to
your best testing indicators right and
this is like almost 30 years before
practicing she didn't like you have some
sense he was digging the urgent to talk
about Bachelet you was some craziness
for peace that's correct
so we the glazes are equal very good
Rick gave three SS plan plus tax
now this queen g2 we're back in business
with checkmate if you have your queen
somewhere I play Queen a screaming for
examples here and then me man
Saturday's three he obviously right that
resided he's super resigned action
points
Raritan he's way into that hi yes so we
ate seven double X Claire and suggested
Mike here good job and then I could
Rick's Erickson is over
that was a good jacket is my
so I went to Reykjavik in 1990 it was
three days in some of them and I play
the open tournament I've heard some
other events and I played a Swedish
friend master and he quit just after
this game to get a lawyer it was funny
about that statement is true puts a
little bit last tournament yes my
trusted my player
I lost the final that way hi so this is
a hope position if you have an old East
CEO of your visa Oh what was the first
where was it emotional exotic what's he
trying to say
yes it's encyclopedia I'm going to be
officially anyways those were out the
fifties and sixties and even E is and so
on if you want to know more about it
over your vocal yeah so Cheryl all right
so if you have an old copy of the ETL
obviously the CDs g OJT 45 it's blue
diagram oh okay you caught any like
really looks easy oh yeah the blue one
to see okay so in this position which
has never occurred before it says
renamed for is interesting little
suggestion never be played am i part
likely a for the losing room where to
press your books right you with the
right answer
yeah I play chief I notice when he's
like cleaning for he was on protecting
his night because the screen was on d1
and now it's not so if I could get rid
of this tonight I would have good
chances of taking the other one right
Arjun
I played g5 and he put his head down and
shook his head to attend in it I thought
was a sacrifice we play create or
directly see progress on what was that
record
55 now the funny story about this game
which I call before but you forgot and
so as you don't know regarding so I
fight in Iceland and then I flew home by
taking a plane to lots of board and the
difference in temperature was 100
degrees as we raked a victim last war -
37 and then I took the train from losses
were to Brussels when someone I got home
from the train station I walked in the
door my phone rings hello and his mum
went on the best player in Belgium he
just finally on which is in 100 him
hey I'm TJ to him right Fred and he's
like I just got home the tournament as I
just watched as a girl from Iceland so
we're saying how we did and I this was
before the Internet so he couldn't we
didn't know anything who who's in
trouble anyway so I said I'd be doubters
in 25 News with black and from that
sentence he says Queen a fork and I said
how did you know he didn't only one was
and I said he said all I had this
positionally on am i I was considering a
game for what's on the g5 one play 31
said
we analyzed this all things together but
everything it here
roulette every Saturday and then I might
see five and then you play here and put
it before and I want peace
language not anyone what does all gone
what about there one yes okay hey social
right no I want the games I want a piece
I'm gonna peace out
I'm serious okay
so he moves to tonight then I play Queen
say Genichiro so he's play the routine
lon you were still crazy common 1994 now
alright
I'm investing I would take the guest
yeah what do you threaten it's like to
stop it mission where you're saying the
right move for black is the venture
promotion yeah this is it
so you agree a sister-wife okay
so then I won yet so the introvert I'll
go with g5 excellent G pods always be in
circles
remember that okay and footboard okay
now before this game this guy kept
telling me stuff over and over and over
again usually guys do that you got that
and I was going to do and what did I say
don't tell us I'm higher rate than you
he said night okay what's the hint I
thought I thought he because I was very
good both of the goddess anyone like
pray
Papa don't preach what you laugh-in Papa
don't preach
the popular Selfridge yeah oh where are
you
right what you're supposed to say what
crickets or what right huh this is all
in this position as you all notice
during that back-and-forth black is
threatening Jane made this correct who
said the room oh you're still going to
hear you sing louder now even with a
louder you queens you to me and I can
stop it with my favorite move or my
least favorite mode which is very
question right but if I out three or
fish about one so I play is present in
1994 watching those two relate the hive
and the computer slightly prefers that
three slightly so I'll just enough one
I thought me I'm the best okay now the
computer said the people he has two
fonts really change in his center forms
a reason why the center one but two
bishops okay and now we play taboo and
the creator who he resigned so his group
wasn't good so I was giving a lot sort
of somebody who's reading about 2,200
and I said what would you play to reply
we thought a while three or four minutes
and maybe to the movies but which lost
it immediately so this was a very
reasonable looking movements the natural
kind of book and I saw the venom lost to
my phone play
I'm sorry letter to computer garden okay
so you were black but victory like
Claudia was pretty good
what's a reasonable looking move for
black well the first things you think up
what's that
in Oulu spare time otherwise you with
the radiator say loud in turn g5 that
loses a medium it actually plays but
these mob looks pretty good right
defy he's work enjoy be some weirdo a
bizarre that table d5 now this was the
funniest thing that happened to me in
chess at a reasonable level obvious if
I'm playing a 500 fun yourself atoms but
this is the finest in having a real turn
against a real opponent this regulation
us championship before you were born
even had last known as in 76 play ball
kinda change
okay but he's not reading this decision
okay I need my food which wins any
instantly designed like I don't know but
it's o'clock and even those terrible in
Ohio it
he almost reads I have a break apart but
others this movie would be in shock that
you didn't see it which he didn't
easy honey has a lot of the biggest
reservation up lesson happens that
mentum okay so what's the winning move
for life reassure game when you solve
the puzzle
you call you already saw
I'll play it I'll say a secret in this
position before he plays d5 this move
doesn't win he let me win would be fine
that helps me that gives you somebody
what this Claudia made a d5 looks good
those funds can less is the wrong in
addition peaking generator not a serious
question if there should be two in yes
then why was be part of it why do not
want to follows on defense
I'm that version how guess you can
advance everyone what it is because I
thought the ball was 96 on would win
that is actually intake in same time who
I'm confused odious there's somebody
else does you don't want to hear you
hear anything all you can hear is you're
doing great what's that may be what bias
kind of players likes Plus never never
no injures
ah you like that the way yeah you know
why OS was being updated all right so I
was there 63 but she obviously missed so
much fun and then he got residing
nonetheless
now he should resign well you shouldn't
resign after half a second that makes an
animal you miss it could be done
fricassee so you play d5 that's when
birthday see three one three seconds I
was waiting for d5 obviously she takes I
blend the skewer you see how I'm skewing
over here you see all that so he makes
my cream I'd say his run taking place
maybe that basis is legal now
this one was a v6 I'm resigning please
lady five my position of faith with
various threats such as Bishop h6 made
also fish should be for chat also came
prayer garden so there's two a DJ escape
he just like ready to chat which miss
teenage homers and I mean queen here
chat always plays me to that one that is
really doing or he just played by age
three shot and then quickie five shots
that's also doesn't do any nice closets
a flat this shouldn't I read between
sleep not meeting visit a cheese so I so
I was hoping after hearing play d5 he
did and I played here as well but I was
fine because my bishop that activated by
hit funny move d5 America my husband and
I thought all my students you know on
the whole white smoke like your phone in
the capture or chat should help
he didn't analyze 463 and he weakened is
that great by the way my fish get active
here if you didn't play d5 to clinic a
few recommended food than funny
that was awesome about this you wouldn't
be preaching terrible so I look to sky
up yesterday now was just Elvis Esther I
was on the internet and I thought he was
alive I was already going and one of the
articles was six year old beats national
master in ten minute match and he was
the national master truth hurts other
one was most six-year-olds are 2200
strain so that was bragging I wonder I
wonder who could be what what do you
mean
alright least but not last all right so
the funny story about this guy so
occasionally somebody who's really good
at shot is really good something up and
set a person here is here in vixen air
piston was two times you Miss junior
champion but in quick sense completely
because he's an actor he's like nectar
custard is Hedison so whatever likes to
deny now Larson would talk about non
Cheston a snowman now how long the man
people that used to play chess you doing
like we got here at piston several years
ago and I show the Wikipedia 15 the
while anyway Matt Larsen is now in
Minnesota
doing a forward research project on from
math nonsense possibly not
oh by the way one of the speakers coming
later is resistant with any place of
what can you do not start everyone
because it the biggest classes on earth
is going against the pole all right
anyway this was good air piston engine
quick shuts yes so I find it okay and we
punch the [ __ ] is already we ever played
the used to determine the flex with the
partners was down have it we didn't
poker yeah alright so my opponent is
plays route 57 establishing the
Cheerilee quality right are you yeah
okay so this is the last puzzle of the
day being black to play it with the
puzzle gray what's funny is before this
game started I said funny 421 thought my
caring like this during was illegal and
I was right but they said he had that
friends okay because they agree with me
at first they couldn't find a good
repair
absolutely Stephanie Walker is going to
find Ted white who started its black
hair who you say is life here correct
I was so surprised were right get happen
rotates eating Cadillacs he's so good
that's all income a classic one is a
clay master even like weight as a
pitcher raised you cry nice not kidding
human right now he said her 52 and for
what if she was right he complete even
like that at JA I had it but we're 52
BAM
that enough of it see that is how I was
faulted turns why why why are you
talking so close alright so he took my
brothers under right now your move yeah
good job good patina so now this thing
is very safe except for one thing it's
not the king he get I thought BC One so
he is was it easier are just adjustable
give really good I think it's pretty
good alright Quincy once the hydrogen
suggests a move that's the argument
good luck now I wish you luck
how many of you resigned any 93 Zion TTI
really resigning with trash but he
played Queen e2
I think that's doing look like it's
another moon now what do I do
and here your design if you play King f1
where 92 9f or 55 what would you guys
like you guys won't like that absolutely
means I should not like that as much to
be literate v8 and I'm winning but this
is more waiting I mean when I say I
think this is more winning than in
Poland right Arjun you see what the
threat is
hold on okay okay okay what's the wrong
answer
head west what's blacks correct
you want to make sure you saw it that's
brilliant
rotation how it happened yeah anything
but my face me you could have said
vertex v1 v1 you sent a snapchat
art is a 30 answer like we should be
five right Queens you want really what
does a creepy ones need for you to see
for exposing what that's not mean one
rather Ricky wants quicker yeah so Ted
west right is usual Friday that's why
I'm reading out time regularly attending
the good so that's a nice v3 check
really do yeah and then you go to the
chest lighter amazing because it may
give a chest life and what you know care
is gonna be sure to just life right yeah
I guess that's why producers you what
you do what save you oh you guys know
why I well I just something I think of
what he's done I think I'm going to
cover it just lies and the same issue I
was also on the back cover
laughter a separate reasons yeah anyway
like technically on the inside
so before you are older a year old yeah
you go broke it up leave you have you in
a while there's also a you know class
[Music]